so let's talk um you said something
interesting before let's talk a bit
about
first amendment because i think you are
filling a void
that big tech has not done themselves um
and so this is i'm i believe in um free
speech i think it's there's a reason
it's first and i think it's
um foundational to um
civilization in many ways and developed
civilization today
and democracy in particular but i
believe
that you can say whatever you want to
extend into
you know it's outside of what's called
like what's predefined legal hate speech
um but what i don't like about big tech
is that we've like leaned on that
but we've also leaned the other way
where we're like but if people are free
to say whatever they want
our algorithm is still going to
distribute that nonsense
like across our platforms too um
and they're they're trying to figure it
out they being the google facebook
apples of the world
um and what you've done
is said apple stop
facebook stop trying to in this case
twitter stop trying to
be the first amendment police here and
put it on the person
you're like okay people are saying
whatever they want i'm gonna just
filter out what i'm comfortable seeing
and i don't want to distribute it and
share it in my face
is that the future in your in your
opinion where it's going to be less on
the
the big tech companies to filter this
out and more on
us i think people actually happy with
that it's kind of what you've done what
are you what are your thoughts there
yeah there's so many things i want to
address uh the first
is around like free speech or allowing
people to say what they want
um i think a very
simplistic interpretation of this is
like yes everybody can just say what
they want and like
we should aspire to that on platforms um
and we don't put any sort of uh
restrictions on what can be posted
and and that's like the truest form of
free speech in practice
because of things like abuse and
harassment many people
can't actually speak freely because they
know that if they speak they will be
inundated with harassment
and the repercussions to that are so
much that people are self-silencing and
i sense this as well like in my own
posting online
i know there's certain topics that if i
talk about them the repercussions will
be so negative that i
will wish i had not done that and so i
will preemptively hold back and so
that's not really freedom of speech then
like what you're doing is allowing
the like unchecked abuse to silence
certain people
and so even that conception of like
first amendment like you said freedom of
speech is flawed in that way
but building on that idea is um
[Music]
this notion that it's not just speech
there are repercussions to it there are
things that happen
after the speech um and for a long time
we've kind of viewed
the words or media that people post
online is like that's it
and not really understanding we're not
understanding what are the ramifications
of that
um we got to see on january 6th
some very clear ramifications of
allowing people to post things interact
online it's not just that they're
sharing content with each other
it does turn into offline world
consequences
this brings me to a next point which is
that our
governance models don't understand this
so when i talk about governance it's um
both things like offline
laws so we have the constitution kind of
we've
talked about first amendment
constitution um
and other like the other laws that apply
in
physical nation states and local
jurisdictions
um but there's also sort of like the
governance of online
worlds where we don't really have the
equivalent there
um so there's laws offline so if you do
certain things that are illegal that
violate the laws
you may face repercussions for them
online we don't have
an equivalent system of governance and
we also don't have a system of
governance that
contains both offline and online worlds
together and
understands that the ramifications of
online speech can actually be
let's say murder or insurrection
and because we don't have a system of
law or governance that understands that
we're very limited
uh right now to trying to appeal to
offline world
systems of governance like are there
some laws that you have
violated in the office have you like
incited an insurrection
have you incited violence and that's the
only way we take any kind of action
against
online speech whereas there's a whole
bunch of stuff that's happened
in between the online speech and like
murder
that are bad we joke about irl versus
url right like url online
irl in real life that distinction is so
blurred
right like especially in this past year
when almost all of our interactions have
been digital
yeah there's not really a big difference
between things rl
weirdly even though it's online right
you but you said something i had never
thought
of and it's this concept of
uh basically when
this first amendment was written and for
hundreds of years
it was people will say whatever they
want because it
it's just it's just noise um there
wasn't like streamlined ways to
communicate and then freedom of press
was part of it
as well but now you're talking about um
other parts of freedom of speech that
are
almost uniquely on the internet so like
it's one thing for one person to start
shouting hate speech at the top of
mountain or saying something mean
it's another thing if they're talking to
twenty thousand hundred thousand a
million people because that's like
uh a various and it that's like an
assembly and it may not be peaceful
based on that language and now
and then in the internet you're not just
talking about words you can be talking
about
pictures and videos and animation and
god knows what this problem that we are
facing is
so big that we have to reconceptualize
all of governance and i think it's a
phase shift that's as significant
as say going from
tribal communities to feudal states
or feudal states with like monarchy
to modern liberal democracies like this
is a very big transition in how all of
society functions
and just quibbling about like one
particular law
doesn't feel like it's going to get us
to where we need to be in terms of
governance
and one other thing i would point out is
um
the rules that determine how people
interact
uh come in a few forms so there's laws
where
we have this idea that like laws are
very strong and if they're
uh violated they will be
enforced by some form of punishment or
fines or there's there's some kind of
enforcement there
but most of what people do
in the offline world is not just
skirting the edge of what's legal or not
there are also social norms around like
what is acceptable behavior
and how do i want to behave amongst
other people and
i pick up cues from others around me so
even if things aren't
illegal i won't necessarily do them
much easier to shout some on twitter
than actually look someone in the eye
and say the same thing
most of the stuff like for example the
people that would hate on hillary
clinton
i would just beg many of them to look
her in the eyes human being and say that
because hillary is a very impressive
person right like and
you know like his stuff you know is that
what you're saying yeah so i'm saying
like
there's there's a stuff that should be
clearly delineated
as this is not acceptable and if you if
you violate these rules
there will be repercussions to it
there's that set of things that
uh we probably need to be a bit stronger
on right now there's very little
governance of anything happening online
consequence is just being an [ __ ] on
the internet and and the fact that like
even some of the things that are
delineated is not acceptable don't get
enforced that way means that people
implicitly understand that they can
still get away with doing
things that are not so it's frowned upon
slap on their wrists
outside of things but i think there's
also quite a bit that we need to do in
terms of setting better
norms online so maybe it's not
enforceable
anyway but it's enforceable in the sense
of like the community may shun you or
you may be looked down upon or like
we evolve social norms that are just
better for interacting with each other
and sure there may be some range of what
people personally find acceptable or not
um like just like in the offline world
you'll see people who are
nicer or ruder and it's all like within
some
general distribution of like what is
appropriate social behavior
so my future of censorship for example
censorship maybe that's defining like
the absolute worst things that you're
not allowed to say
but i think that's a very limiting way
of looking at
all of our online systems and how people
interact and our participants in a
digital ecosystem or digital society
it's not just defined by
what are the worst things that you're
not allowed to do but also like where
are the norms what are people
expecting in terms of interaction with
each other
where it's just socially acceptable
behaviors on the internet
and right now it's the wild west well
there's nothing that's technically not
socially acceptable because everything
is
it's just it's just a mess where like
there's stuff you say online you could
never get away with in person because
whether it's common sense or common
decency or whatever we've all agreed to
as like rule of law and like social
norms
it's unacceptable you mentioned this
idea of like the wild west i think
that's a very good
metaphor to use as well when you look at
the lack of enforcement but lack of laws
and
justice and in that environment
we kind of see mob dress as a vigilante
justice
and i think what people often will call
cancel culture fits into that where
because there's no real system of
enforcement that we can trust like
there's no law enforcement that we
think will in most cases when there are
violations like go
and follow through on the enforcement
um we end up having individual citizens
piling on to one person who
does something that's deemed not
acceptable
and the punishment in those cases ends
up often being pretty disproportionate
to what the original
supposed crime was and
it just feels very imperfect because you
do want there to be some accountability
until you you get the sense of like okay
this person said something was very
inappropriate they did something that
was inappropriate
they should be held to account but
because there's not a good system of
justice and you have a huge pile on from
the entire internet it does feel
a little bit over the top and so we go
from like no accountability to
way too much accountability in certain
cases in most cases none
and i think the solution is not like
let's get rid of accountability
it's like how do we design a better
system of governance and law
and enforcement so that the
accountability is commensurate with
the yes like if you made a terrible
tweet
in your teens if you
behaved inappropriately at a party there
are consequences for those actions
and they should exist does it mean that
you should be unemployable
the rest of your life um except by like
far right-wing organizations like
probably not
right like that's we all make mistakes
hell i do
all the time and i'm sure i'll be
canceled over and over and that's
it's frustrating um and then on the
other hand it's like
okay but harvey weinstein was a disaster
so that guy needs to go to
like you know so there's like there is a
middle ground which the internet doesn't
really like to have right now we don't
really love nuance
um let me ask you this it's gonna come
off as an [ __ ] question so i'm going
to preface it by saying
i'm asking this in the in a human way um
as nicely as i can
do you think we're too sensitive as
society particularly on the internet in
the sense of
like i grew up like sticks and stones
when i break my bones but names will
never
hurt me right like we're all out here
and people are like i'm getting bullied
or there's harassment but the reality is
like
it's just dumb people saying mean things
the type of person it takes to say some
of the comments you were mentioning that
harassed you like
to me i'm like oh who cares about that
person he's clearly or she
probably usually he a sociopath pay them
no mind
move on and on
so that's like where maybe sometimes i
lean but other times we have people
going the complete opposite like this is
a travesty we have to do all these
things
have we built ourselves up to be too
sensitive
to overreact to time like what are your
thoughts on kind of our
the general sensitivity level
of your internet users and the press i
think too
i think there's um
kind of subtext to this question which
is the context and
a collapse of context
and when you frame that question you
pose that question i immediately think
of different people's reactions to
certain things given what context they
are in
so for example we're talking about like
negative comments
um maybe one negative comment
you can brush off and it's not that big
a deal you can just say like ignored the
trolls
um when it happens
every day all day it's very difficult to
shake that off
and i think when you have folks who
don't experience
the sort of like persistent harassment
only looking at individual examples the
response to just shake it off
is not understanding the context of like
dealing with this non-stop um
and i think there is a very real mental
health impact
and um it it's maybe a
bit more understandable for folks who
have dealt with it a lot to
to say like oh when you when you point
out one bad tweet
just shake it off or you see what's in
my timeline right now like you shake
this off [ __ ] like
so there's a pretty big difference there
like i could show you
a couple of the the tweets i've had to
see over the last couple of days
and they might all seem fine um
or like it's easy to brush it off but in
the context of like dealing with this
for
i don't know how many like over 10 years
and a lot of it and sometimes it's huge
pylons
um it it feels very different
another analogy i have heard sometimes
is like um
if somebody steps on your foot by
accident and you respond really
negatively
they may say like why are you so upset
like why are you so sensitive
like i just accidentally stepped on your
foot like you don't even like get upset
at me
but if you're the person whose foot got
stepped on and you've been stepped on
like thousands of times and your foot is
sore already
then when this other person like
actually steps on you
it already hurts and it's a huge pattern
of problematic behavior and hurt that
you have accrued
and so the responses feel different and
they feel mismatched and like both sides
may
feel upset at the other because
they're just operating from different
contexts i think that is important to
call it we have such different
experiences and
maybe something that's worse about um
the online world is that
it can be harder to understand what
someone else is dealing with so
i don't know what your notifications
look like on twitter you don't know what
mine look like
it's harder for me to have an
understanding of what you may be dealing
with or for you
um likewise versus in the real world if
we're sitting in the same room
or we're standing in the same room and i
see a bunch of people that come over to
you and are shouting me things i can get
a sense of like you're dealing with a
lot right now
and it's harder to see that online or
you can't see
dms very easily um of other of other
folks online
so these private messages these direct
messages they're meant to be one-on-one
communication so nobody else has access
to
what you're seeing and so you don't
really know like
what other crap somebody is dealing with
privately
versus in the offline world when when
people are harassing me on the street
the pastor if i can kind of see if
there's somebody there they could
overhear the shouting or
that kind of thing um so a lot of this
context collapses
[Music]
online
[Music]
you